130 milliarden euro das ist ein batzen
geld mit der die bundesregierung die
wirtschaft wieder ankurbeln will
57 punkte umfasst das paket von
kinderbonus bis hin zu einer senkung der
mehrwertsteuer
aber was bringen diese maßnahmen
eigentlich am ende wer sind hier die
gewinner wer darf sich freuen und wer
geht leer aus und wie nachhaltig ist
dieses paket eigentlich das wollen wir
uns jetzt gleich mal genauer anschauen
wie immer könnt ihr natürlich eure
fragen stellen postet sie einfach hier
unten in die kommentare
und ich würde dann weitergehen an den
präsident des kieler instituts für
weltwirtschaft an professor gabriel
felbermayr der mir jetzt auch live
zugeschaltet ist guten abend herr
professor felbermayr herr felbermayr die
große koalition die spricht von einem
kraftpaket mit booms würden sie das auch
so nennen
ja das ist natürlich eine ansage die
bundesregierung zu treffen wo es sie wie
ihr vor allem zuversicht stärken da ich
leute leute sollen wieder mehr
konsumieren sollen aufgenommen schöpfen
da gehört diese rhetorik dazu und in der
tat es ist ein großes projekt das hier
beschlossen würde größer als wir
erwartet haben vor ein paar tagen war
auch die rede von 80 milliarden jetzt
ist unter 30
also ich schon gehörig kraft drinnen
europas wirklich ist die deutsche
wirtschaft adresse kann so wie das in
dem papier der bundesregierung steht das
werden wir sehen es gibt eine ganze
reihe von fragezeichen auf die wir noch
keine antwort haben und das wollen wir
uns jetzt gleich auch erst mal im detail
anschauen
vorher gucken wir uns mal an was denn
eigentlich im paket drin steckt das
konjunkturpaket geschnürt im kanzleramt
hat gewaltige dimensionen es geht um 130
milliarden euro größte überraschung die
mehrwertsteuer sie sinkt ab dem ersten
juli für ein halbes jahr von 19 auf 16
prozent
der ermäßigte satz etwa für lebensmittel
von sieben auf fünf gesamtkosten hier
etwa 20 milliarden euro
thema familie für jedes
kindergeldberechtigte kind gibt es eine
einmalzahlung von 300 euro
außerdem werden drei milliarden euro in
den ausbau von kitas und ganztagsschulen
investiert die umstrittene autokauf
prämie für verbrenner kommt nicht
stattdessen werden die prämien für
hybrid und elektrofahrzeuge bis ende
nächsten jahres auf 6000 euro verdoppelt
hilfen gibt es auch für die kommunen die
massiven steuerausfälle will der bund
mit etwa sechs milliarden euro
ausgleichen und dann noch neue
unterstützung für unternehmen die
besonders schlimm von der krise
betroffen sind mit insgesamt 25
milliarden soll eine pleitewelle
verhindert werden
der größte einzelbetrag in
konjunkturpaket ist der bereich
klimaschutz und technologien der zukunft
dafür gibt es insgesamt 50 milliarden
euro
so diese ganzen einzelnen punkte wollen
wir uns jetzt mal genauer anschauen herr
felbermayr lassen sie uns mal mit der
mehrwertsteuer beginnen das ist ja wohl
es gab auch schon genannt eine der
grössten überraschung und das echo
darauf ist ja ziemlich geteilt die einen
sagen das ist sinnvoll
es gibt auch viele die sagen er da wird
geld verbrannt oder die stellen sich die
frage
hier gibt es zum beispiel schon einen
kommentar bei youtube da wird gefragt
wird denn das produkt für den
verbraucher auch tatsächlich günstiger
wenn die mehrwertsteuer gesenkt oder
steigen steigt nur der gewinn der
großunternehmer und das würde ich
einfach mal so an sie weitergeben wie
sinnvoll ist jetzt ja die
mehrwertsteuersenkung hatte youtube eine
ganz wichtige frage gestellt in der tat
ist offen in welchem ausmaß die
unternehmen die mehrwertsteuersenkung
weitergeben werden ob sie wirklich die
zweieinhalb prozent die ein produkt
günstiger werden könnte zur gänze an die
konsumenten weiter reicht davon gehen
wir nicht aus da zwei gründe sprechen
dafür dass das nicht komplett
weitergegeben wird erstens ist das eine
befristete mehrwertsteuerabsenkung für
die unternehmen werden
also ist nicht anpassen vor allem wenn
es um produkte geht die ohnehin nicht
sehr hochpreisig sind das 1 8 cent
runter und dann am ersten jahren des
nächsten jahres wieder auf das lässt man
und wir wissen sozusagen das ganz normal
ist dass die mehrwertsteuer nicht zur
gänze an die konsumenten weitergereicht
wird insofern von den zwanziger jahren
kommen vielleicht 10 12 am ende bei den
konsumenten wirklich an und die zweite
große frage die wird stellen müssen ist
was ist eigentlich der zweck den man
damit erreichen will
wir wollen ja die konjunktur ankurbeln
das heißt wir wollen auch wieder mehr
konsum
der konsum ist eingebrochen die stark
eingebrochenen deutschland im zuge der
krise aber er ist nicht eingebrochen und
weil die leute kein geld mehr hätten wir
sehen dass die sparquote in deutschland
stark gestiegen ist das heißt die
einkommen die bei vielen bereichen
natürlich bei den kurzarbeitern oder
auch bei solo selbstständigen teilweise
eingebrochen sind sind aber in der
gesamten deutschen volkswirtschaft
relativ stabil geblieben was nicht
stabil geblieben sind die konsumausgaben
das heißt nicht dass bahn ist höher
geworden und das wiederum bedeutet
eigentlich ist es nicht so dass die
leute zu wenig geld hätten es ist auch
nicht so dass die güte zu teuer wäre
sondern die kaufzurückhaltung kommt aus
einer großen verunsicherung hat angst um
die jobs man weiß nicht wie es
weitergeht und das konjunkturpaket wird
nur dann erfolgreich sein wenn es diese
zuversicht ein bisschen stärken kann
das ist viel wichtiger als die senkung
der mehrwertsteuer
das erreichen kann hier wird auch noch
ein spannender aspekt angesprochen von
tobias bei facebook der auch darauf
hinweist dass ja auch die umstellung der
mehrwertsteuersätze zum beispiel in
kassen bezahlt werden muss und dass das
auch ein aufwand ist das ist spannend
und eine frage würde ich allerdings auch
noch mal gerne an sich stellen und zwar
selbst wenn es jetzt so ist dass diese
paar prozentpunkte weitergegeben werden
an den kunden ist das denn wirklich
einen kaufanreiz länder etwas irgendwie
knapp drei prozent günstiger ist als
normalerweise also wenn was 20 30
prozent günstiger ist dann kauft man
doch aber doch nicht bei so ein paar
kleinen prozenten oder
das kommt ganz darauf an welche produkte
wir haben sie natürlich über das gepäck
beim bäcker ein paar cent billiger
werden sollten das macht keinen großen
unterschied aber wenn wir über große
anschaffungen reden über die renovierung
eines badezimmers den kauf eines autos
auch oder von neuen möbel waschmaschinen
solche dinge da können 3% natürlich
schon einen unterschied machen und das
möchte die regierung auch es sollen
ausgaben vorgezogen werden denn am im
januar 2021 ist dieser drei prozent
bonus oder zweieinhalb sehen sie
eigentlich dieser bonus dann wieder weg
und die frage dass des hörers oder des
zuschauers natürlich kostet die
umstellung etwas ökonomen sprechen davon
soll wenn du kochst es kostet also etwas
ein menü zum beispiel neu zu schreiben
aber in zeiten der digitalisierung ist
das nicht das große thema deswegen war
einig dass wir da keine großen sorgen
haben soll
lassen sie uns jetzt auch mal auf die
familien schauen weil die sind ja jetzt
auch besonders betroffen gerade in der
krise da wurde ja ein kinderbonus
beschlossen eine einmalzahlung von 300
euro einfach für alle
und hier gibt es schon kommentare dazu
die sind durchaus kritisch wie zum
beispiel schreibt bei youtube 300 euro
sind gar nichts die verpuffen einfach
wenn du kinder hast die frage an sie was
bringt das dieser kinderbonus ja also
ich habe auch kinder drei davon und in
der tat ist es so dass die 300 euro
einmalzahlung keinen großen unterschied
machen
aber es ist natürlich in vielen familien
die die budgets hart an der kante genäht
sind macht das natürlich schon eine
erleichterung und wir müssen auch sehen
es ist nicht so dass das für alle ist
denn der 300 euro bonus wird mit den
familien frei betragende
kinderfreibetrag verrechnet das heißt
gut verdienende amt und diesen bonus
nicht es ist wirklich für die haushalte
mit den geringeren oder mittleren
einkommen
und dort gibt es schon einige millionen
in deutschland
die so schlecht ausgestattet sind mit
geld das diese 300 euro pro kind eine
erleichterung sind aber es ist natürlich
so dass in einem konjunkturpaket mit
dieses das jetzt geschnürt wird nicht
sozusagen eine komplette neuordnung der
familienpolitik gemacht werden kann das
wäre zu viel verlangt also im prinzip
ist das ja auch das argument dass dann
eben doch die geringer verdienenden
familien profitieren und die viel
verdienen familien dann doch nicht weil
der freibetrag nicht gesenkt worden ist
das ist dann das argument was gegen alle
spricht die sagen das ist das
gießkannenprinzip dass man erst mal
denken könnte wenn man hört alle kriegen
diesen kinderbonus
das haben sie jetzt gerade auch noch mal
erklärt was steckt denn in diesem paket
drin wo man sagen kann das hilft den
familien langfristig und wurde auch was
für alleinerziehende getan er
langfristig ist für die familie
sicherlich gut wenn ein bisschen mehr in
die ganztagsbetreuung investiert wird
wenn die schulen renoviert werden da ist
sozusagen in dem zukunfts teil des
paketes ein bisschen etwas drin
das ist für die familien gut vielleicht
nachhaltig auch mehrwert wirtschaftlich
mehr wert als die einmalzahlung von 300
euro für die alleinerziehende ist auch
etwas enthalten
der alleinerziehende
unterstützungsbeitrag das soll
verdoppelt werden von knapp 2000 euro
auf 4000 euro über zwei jahre also auch
die ist gedacht worden
insgesamt glaube ich ist das vertretbar
was in diesem paket für familien gemacht
wurde selbst wenn natürlich die bäume
nicht in den himmel wachsen
hier kommt noch mal eine nachfrage
gerade von patricia bei facebook die
frage ab wann denn dieser kinderbonus in
kraft tritt ob das eigentlich sofort ist
das ist nach meinem wissen ab juli ist
einmal sind die 300 euro die sollen die
drei tranchen bezahlt werden 300 euro
also ich gehe davon aus dass dieses geld
schnell bei den familien ankommt
bisschen vorlauf braucht natürlich um
das zu administrieren lassen sie uns als
nächstes mal von den familien rüber
waren dann zu den ganz großen branchen
zur automobilindustrie da wurde ja vorab
viel diskutiert jetzt ist klar es gibt
milliarden kaufprämien allerdings nicht
für verbrenner sondern für e autos
finden sie dass es der richtige schritt
die frage ist ob man diese erhöhung der
schon existierenden kauf bringen wir
wirklich braucht es gibt hier schon
jetzt eine kaufprämie von 3000 euro für
den elektro auto diese kaufprämie wird
von der wirtschaft verdoppelt das
insgesamt 6000 euro
bisher haben diese kaufprämie nicht
wirklich einen elektroauto boom
ausgelöst in deutschland jetzt kommt er
etwas dazu auch befristet wieder bis zum
ende des jahres die frage ist ob wenn
wirklich die nachfrage steigen sollte
die deutsche wirtschaft überhaupt in der
lage ist diese autos zu produzieren
die frage ist wie viel davon wird
importiert werden also wieviel
unterstützt wirklich deutsche jobs und
deutsche löhne
das sind alles offene fragen ich bin
froh ehrlich gesagt das ist nicht eine
allgemeine abwrackprämie gibt das war ja
zu befürchten ich bin froh dass die
brancheninteressen einer mächtigen
branche in deutschen automobilbranche
sich nicht hier durchsetzen konnten dass
wir also mehr gleichbehandlung haben
das leiste zum beispiel die
mehrwertsteuer die hilft wirklich allen
branchen
insofern ist das positiv aber so richtig
begeistert mich diese diese diese prämie
für elektroautos ehrlich gesagt auch
nicht
ein solcher gestern immer wieder in der
pressekonferenz betont und zwar wie
zukunftsweisend das paket ist und auch
angela merkel hat sich heute noch mal im
zdf dazu geäußert gehören da mal rein
wir verbinden kurzfristiges handeln
sonst ist es kein konjunkturprogramm
dann ist es normal dass handel
mit dem mit der tatsache dass wir in die
neuen entwicklungen investieren und das
ist klima- und das ist digitalisierung
das sind die beiden großen umbrüche
unseres wirtschaftens und dann setzen
wir darauf dass wir eben auch in
forschung entwicklung stärker werden
neue energieformen zum beispiel und wir
schaffen verlässlichkeit auch für die
wirtschaft und für die bürgerinnen und
bürger mit den stromkosten und mit den
sozialversicherungsbeiträgen
also sollen auch weichen für die zukunft
gestellt werden mit diesem paket kann
das aus ihrer sicht so funktionieren die
dinge schon also da ist die hälfte
ungefähr das geld ist der 130 milliarden
die hier in die hand genommen werden
soll ja in die zukunft investiert werden
das wird sehr viel getan für das
anstoßen von forschung das halte ich für
gut und positiv und auch die deckelung
der eeg-umlage dass die nicht weiter
steigen soll sich ein stück weit senken
soll auf sechs cent pro kilowattstunde
ist etwas das die energiewende antreiben
wird strom günstiger werden damit die
leute umsteigen von gasheizungen auch
wärmepumpe von witzin auto auf
elektroauto und das sind effekte die
bleiben werden
die deckelung der
sozialversicherungsbeiträge 40 prozent
dieser arbeitnehmer und arbeitgeber
teilen diese deckelung ist allerdings
temporär also die fällt weg nach einer
gewissen zeit und dann werden die 20 22
würde das seien dann würden dann die
sozialversicherungsbeiträge
wahrscheinlich steigen müssen um die
kosten die erst bei den krankenkassen
und der rentenversicherung in der
arbeitslosenversicherung auflaufen auch
durch die krise um die stemmen zu können
also teile davon sehe die zukunft
gerichtet ganz klar
aber natürlich ist die finanzierung
dieses pakets auch in die zukunft
verschoben nicht insofern kommentar
belastungen die heute noch nicht
sichtbar sind aber den nächsten zehn
zwanzig jahren auch abgesondert werden
müssen da würde ich gern noch mal
genauer darauf eingehen der bund der
steuerzahler der nennt dieses paket
nämlich auch unfassbar teuer ist das so
dass wir uns diese 130 milliarden euro
leisten können oder geht das jetzt alles
zu lasten der nächsten generation
also der steuerzahler sagt es sei
unfassbar teil hatte natürlich recht wir
reden über gewaltige summen
130 milliarden die kommen ja noch dazu
bereits beschlossenen programmen da
haben wir die 156 milliarden die im
ersten nachtragshaushalt stehen dann
werden die rücklagen aufgelöst aus allen
möglichen in allen möglichen bereichen
in den sozialversicherungen insgesamt
100 milliarden euro
also wir reden schon von sehr große
summe ja allerdings sehen wir auch in
diesen tagen in der größten
wirtschaftskrise der
nachkriegsgeschichte
und das bedeutet wir müssen hier auch
ordentlich aufs gaspedal treten und
ordentlich bums erzeugen wie die
bundesregierung sagt insofern ist das
schon in ordnung antizyklische
fiskalpolitik nennt wird das in der
ökonomie und wenn der zyklus so
einbricht und die krise so stark dieses
buchs und auch viel geld in die hand
nehmen können wir uns das leisten
die gute nachricht ist ja deutschland
hat ja da wurde viel kritik geübt aber
hat ja in den letzten zehn jahren einen
sehr vorsichtigen fiskalpolitischen kurs
gefahren wir haben die vorschule und den
prozent des bruttoinlandsproduktes unter
60 prozent gedrückt und jetzt haben wir
den fiskalpolitischen spielraum
es ist ja so dass wir nicht aus reinem
spaß am sparen das geld zusammengehalten
haben in den letzten jahren sondern
genau mit dem ziel in einer krise diese
feuerkraft zu haben und letzter punkt
die 130 milliarden euro die jetzt in dem
paket stehen
die sind nicht gleichzusetzen mit neuer
verschuldung und den ungefähr die hälfte
aus diesem paket kann man mit den
bereits im bundestag beschlossenen
finanzrahmen abdecken also sich 156
milliarden die schon erwähnt habe die
sind doch nicht voll ausgeschöpft da ist
noch geld da für die 130 und es gibt
auch noch eine rücklage im bundesbudget
hat ist der flüchtlings rücklage kommt
dann auch noch mal 40 milliarden euro
die man für die finanzierung einsetzen
kann also es geht nicht eins zu eins in
neue schulden wenn wir uns jetzt dieses
gesamtpaket mal anschauen gibt es da den
einen gewinner der am meisten profitiert
nein ich glaube das paket ist ja so
beschlossen wurden von der großen
koalition dass möglichst viele auch
etwas von dem geldsegen haben
das ist so lange fort einer der großen
koalition dass sie eben auch breite
bevölkerungsschichten abdeckt und
bedient das kann man auch kritisieren
nicht das paket ab 59 einzelbereiche da
wird auch und das tierwohl geht nacht
und die waldbesitzer sollen ein bisschen
geld gekommen
also die grundidee die dass wir
politisch trägt ist ja schon dass
möglichst viele bevölkerungsschichten
ein klein wenig von dieser von diesen
hilfen profitieren sollten
ich glaube ich ist auch politisch
umgesetzt schreibt auch zum beispiel
jemand bei twitter da wird an vielen
kleinen schräubchen gedreht aber was man
schon sagen muss wenn ich jetzt hier mal
so durch eure kommentare scroller dass
sie sich doch viele zu wort melden die
sagen dass sie finden dass bestimmte
gruppen nicht berücksichtigt werden ich
lese hier zum beispiel einmal was über
pflege was mehrfach kam ist sind die
solo selbstständigen im bereich messebau
aber auch woanders single haushalte
werden auch genannt die an und keine
kinder haben also diesen kinderbonus
nicht bekommen rentner werden genannt
deshalb die frage an sie wurde da irgend
eine gesellschaftliche gruppe vergessen
hätte es irgendwelche hilfen doch noch
mehr geben müssen
naja also eine gruppe die tatsächlich
schon von anfang an der krise nicht
wirklich im zentrum der regulierung
stand das sind die kleinunternehmer solo
selbstständige oder unternehmer mit
wenigen mitarbeitern die bekomme zwar
auch bestimmte hilfen aber nur zum
abdecken ihrer fixkosten und das
einkommen mit dem der unternehmer
erleben muss oder das solo
selbstständige da gibt es nur am ende
die grundsicherung sprich hartz 4 das
ist dann doch ein für viele ein relativ
tiefer fall
also insofern
ist da schon eine bevölkerungsgruppe die
auch mengenmäßig groß ist wir haben ja
viele kleine unternehmer in deutschland
drei millionen nicht also die da
sicherlich in einem anderen art und
weise bedient werden als andere nicht
mehr beim kurzarbeitergeld reden wir von
60 bis 70 80 prozent lohnersatz und
befehle des selbständigen ist der fall
eben sehr viel tiefer
andere gruppen die zwar jetzt nicht
direkt hilfen bekommen wie zum beispiel
die rentner profitieren ab ersten juli
von einer sehr ordentlichen
rentenerhöhung die steigt um dreieinhalb
prozent im westen um 4,2 prozent im
osten
und das ist also mengenmäßig sogar das
größere produkte programm als der
mehrwertsteuersenkung weil die rentner
plötzlich sehr viel mehr da nicht sehr
viel mehr aber doch deutlich mehr
einkommen haben dass sie auch wirklich
aus auch ausgeben nicht und weiß ich
nicht ausgeben dann vielleicht die
kinder und die enkel professor
felbermayr ganz herzlichen dank für ihre
einordnung und für ihr sicht auf das
konjunkturpaket und ich bedanke mich
natürlich auch ganz herzlich bei euch
für die vielen fragen die hier gekommen
sind ich hoffe viele davon wurden auch
beantwortet nächste woche ist daniel
bröckerhoff hier wieder für euch da ich
wünsche euch jetzt einen schönen abend
tschüss
und wenn ihr mehr über das
konjunkturpaket erfahren möchtet dann
klickt doch mal hier
da beantwortet bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel fragen dazu bei was nun frau
merkel